تقع في قلب مكسيكو سيتي مدرسة
حصرية للأطفال الموهوبين
وفي قلب تلك المدرسة توجد معجزة موهوبة
تبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا تدعى دافني أمازون
تيرا ساكورا تصنع لوس نينوس حتى
لا يكون هناك أي معنى للبرافادوس.
دافني
هي طفلة معجزة أصبحت
أصغر عالمة نفس في العالم في
سن 13 عامًا ، وقد صنفتها مجلة فوربس كواحدة
من أقوى النساء في المكسيك في سن 14 عامًا
، وقد حصلت على درجة الماجستير في التعليم
وهي الآن تنهي
درجة الدكتوراه في القانون كما لو لم يكن ذلك '
يكفي
دافني تتحدث الإنجليزية الفرنسية اللاتينية
والماندرين وتجد وقتًا خلال
اليوم لدراستها جميعًا ، هل قلت إنها تبلغ من
العمر 16 عامًا فقط ، ومن المقدر أن
هناك أكثر من مليون طفل موهوب في
المكسيك مع موهبة تنتظر
الاستفادة منها ، لذا فإن دافني هي  ملتزمة
برعاية المواهب الهائلة لدى
الأطفال الموهوبين في المكسيك ، ولهذا السبب تقوم
بتدريس علم النفس في المدرسة التي
تخرجت منها ذات مرة من مدرسة سنترو دي
أتنزيوني إل تالينتو الإنجليزية للخداع
أنا أتقابل من
ADO المحايد أو لا يوجد نقص في الانتباه
وفرط النشاط جيا muy tarde mi clase
Petera esta Cora porque los ninos estan
exponent or no Cana يتوافق مع
الخناجر يا ماتيرياس están muy por
debajo de sus habilidades المثقفون
yoy tarde mi  clase a piano
Esther bruegger que los ninos Sabourin
de estos temes هي أرجوحة Strega Geritol
فوضوي
[موسيقى]
es por eso que canta Mo's لا تستطيع برمجة
Amoy ITC الابتدائي من طرف
مايسترو sobre atados على سبيل المثال هناك
هذا الطفل الأذكياء العلم الذي يعرف
الجدول الدوري بأكمله مثل ظهر
يده أو هذا الطفل ذي الذاكرة الحادة
التي تسمح له بحفظ كل عظم
في جسم الإنسان هناك هذا
الطفل البالغ من العمر ست سنوات والذي يقدم على
منحدر مثير للاهتمام تعرفه عشرين
ليفرموريوم أونونسبتيوم أونونوكتيوم
[  الموسيقى]
nuestro major objetivo es trainer la الذي
لديه آيس كريم يمثل معظم سكان مدينة ديا دي
مانانا ، وهو جيل ذو مناظر خلابة وهو
دوثراكي بارا ليفار أ في المكسيك بور ل  فيا
تقدمية للغاية
لك